foreign
[Music]
so very delicious because when it came
out I was like oh that's crazy man Fear
Factor you know
is that what he said
I would be surprised I was like why'd
you say and then I remember one
[__] was trying to crawl off the
table and [__] and then she just put
that [__] back in and while he
was alive the Korean lady just went like
she's giving it a haircut it was a great
idea from the aquarium pulled it in
front of like we had a shabi Shabu pot
pulls it in front of us like this and
just went
just like that murdered it yep and then
I was like I was like oh what [__] this
is different country for sure see it's
like really really fun to experience
it's not that good huh no but that's one
of the best worst things I hate because
I was so surprised I've had octopus like
on Sushi or whatever but I was so
surprised at like the difference between
fresh octopus and like frozen it was
very it was very good it was so sweet
and soft and then the life yeah and then
you know when they come out with the
tentacles right that should look like
maggots bro like that's [__] salted
maggots and they tell you they tell you
to chew the [__] out of it because if
you don't chew it fully and you swallow
it and it's still moves it's gonna move
it's gonna try to latch onto your throat
and I was like
that's [__] gross let's let's let's
laugh at it guys and then we're like
eating it and I'm like
this is like piggier one of my favorite
things gelatinous like that Taiwanese
Chinese Pig cartilage it's crunchy it's
just moving don't they put like like a
soy like well this restaurant put um
sesame oil and salt yeah yeah what
um
so like that because of that experience
I really appreciated it because I think
usually if you're trying something
whether or not like you feel the dish
you might not finish it but because I
saw them like pretty much butcher it
right in front of me I'm gonna finish
this thing yeah yeah so like so like it
was cool because you get to choose the
cooked version and then the raw version
what was better and they're both good
they're both really good wow both really
good oh it blew my mind I all of it
though because I just felt I felt Native
American about that [__] yeah yeah in
Korea yeah I better I better I better
eat the [__] nose to tail or whatever
was that octopus good in in terms of
octopi in your life or was it good in
terms of all it was probably the best
octopi oh like class of octopus because
I've one I never had fresh octopus after
that you go back to Frozen and it's just
not the same
I thought to myself I was like I'm good
on this it's all right but did you have
it cooked too yeah oh really and and the
live one you know what I mean that was
like squiggling around and stuff I was
like oh this is really cool experience
but I was like I still prefer like
takoyaki or like fried you know what I
mean really I think it just tastes
better like that yeah grilled Grill
grilled to me I don't think and dream of
the live one like I wouldn't crave that
but the cooked one in that hot pot thing
they did I was like wow so this is what
fresh like I don't have to see it being
murdered in front of me and chopped up
you can say that if it's killed that day
I'm like it's probably gonna taste
pretty good it's different yeah or they
could just cut it behind you here you go
Asian Chinese seafood restaurants they
do that [__] with the lobster let's
bring out too like which one you want
man oh the what is that one
[Laughter]
I need to see the eyes man [__] all
right staring at me how did you know
that that's the one you got because what
if they came up and then they bring it
back and they go okay bust out the
Frozen one oh these are model lobsters
yeah it's a good racket yeah I believed
it every time next week I could have
swore I ate that [__] already
what about you what's the best thing
you've ever eaten
uh okay separate right not best worst
well you can I mean if you have best and
worse I have the best thing
um
I was in
I think Switzerland or something
and it was Christmas
so and you know how in Europe they do
those Christmas markets like big time
yeah they really really separate uh
celebrate Christmas there and at this
Christmas Market there's this one where
they did like some sort of like I don't
know United Nations Night Market type
[__] where like every single Booth was a
different country and I'm like this is
[__] cool so like there's a like
Nepalese dumplings here there's like
whatever over here
and then there's like a uh this this
cheese sandwich place where they would
take a flame so the cheese is like a
block almost like a toast and they would
flame throw the [__] cheese so the
top starts melting and they get the
bread and they smear the cheese like
this that's not the best thing nothing
was really good too so I'm just trying
to paint like how like how like unique
the [__] is
I go to I think I don't even know man I
think it was [__] like Turkish or
some some of those weird countries in
the middle uh there was a sandwich where
they take have you guys ate saw beans
like a Chinese pastry I think so similar
to that where I'm like they took this
bread that was crispy and Flaky I'm like
okay cool like if you know like
countries like turkey there there's like
uh Middle Eastern influence Asian
influenza that's how their Cuisine comes
together so they take this [__]
Turkish style Bean they cut it open they
put like a fried egg in the middle some
meat some whatever and then they closed
it put in the wrapper and they don't
want to eat things at a night market
it's like fresh it's piping hot and then
I remember biting into it and then
tasting like the sausage and then the
melted yolk and then it tasted [__]
good I was like what was this sir he
told me and I went I repeated like 10
times so I have to remember that when I
go back to America I gotta find the
[__] store that sells this literally
like the next day I'm like
[__]
ing sandwiches was it Turkish I don't
even know it's one of those one of my
photo or write it down I have a vlog of
it so I have to find it I have to find
it but it's Turkish or any like gurkish
or market like one of those countries
any of those intersection countries
Azerbaijan Azerbaijan could be Zildjian
symbols
these videos sponsored by yeah
but it was good that was so good yeah
and the closest thing about tried is
stuff like that is a Nadeem would take
me to Afghan restaurants because those
are the few places where you taste
cultures match like he took me to this
place where uh African restaurant and I
tried they called it Mandu too which is
like mandus like dumplings in Korean but
they also call it Mandu there and so
they have dumplings it's wrapped in The
Wonton form
um but like kind of like true to any
type of like uh Melting Pot country
there's some sort of like uh cream sauce
on top and then chili flake crunch thing
and then like a tomato sauce that goes
so I'm like this is like [__] Middle
Eastern Italian and Asian had a baby it
was crazy whoa I like countries like
that what's the worst thing you've ever
eaten
get back to me
I have to remember oh that's true I'll
tell you uh something that was really
terrible that I had I had pho in Indiana
Oh and it was bad and it was at a
Chinese restaurant it was at a Chinese
restaurant do they always have sushi too
maybe I don't know I forgot but it's
only like the Philadelphia roll with
cream cheese you know it was weird
because it looks like pho it doesn't
smell like it the broth is brown you try
it it tastes like water and then like
it's so gross just like describing it
the noodles were like kind of hard I
don't know I just wanted to try it I was
like dude how bad I have to get [__]
everywhere I go if I see it and it's
successful I have to try especially
other countries not necessarily [__]
Indiana or whatever but was it not being
made by a Vietnamese person no it's for
sure
fun your Chinese oh good yeah so they
didn't get the flat noodles they didn't
get anything right the beef was like dry
as [__] I was like damn dude I [__] up
I'm never eating like fall outside of
California anymore any words with the
chef no I didn't care there's really
good friends outside of California yeah
there Texas yeah yeah not really it's
okay the beef is good what about Houston
but it's the because you know in Texas
something bigger and like more flavor so
it's like saltier and it's like way too
more reward for you overdone and and
it's good to some people but preference
to it North Carolina has some of the
best fly I've ever had
it's called Far Far East
out of here
sgv I want to see if we're on the same
page with what's your favorite pho place
in this sgv none of them dude I don't
like anything that's hard like he's he's
like closer to Orange County
no dude Garden Grove and stuff you know
because even your best pho place here
there's like a bunch of them in OC that
are way better it sounds like you're a
fuss snob no it's not even a snob you
can try it yourself and tell me are you
sure about that yes okay I trust you
dude I trust you because the flavor's
kind of good it's okay yeah it's good
it's okay there's none that are good huh
um they're good but they're not great
you know like what's up
I don't know dude there's so many
there's so many other Boomer plays yeah
I know but I just want to see if there's
anyone that's good around here there's a
lot of places that are better than yeah
like for example actually randomly out
here or I guess not SUV technically but
the one phob or something like that uh
in downtown area near Chinatown that one
has one of my favorite chicken fuzz oh
is that the place where they do the
shabufa no that's I don't think so
that's the one that has a fountain
inside yes
the one of all the police officers go to
yeah yes with the fountain it's really
dirty and you look you think you're like
this baby oh yeah get the chicken Pho
there next time just to [__] get the
chicken photo like when you open It's
the weird jacuzzi looking yeah it's a
Jacuzzi looking Fountain yeah with the
[__] extension cords hanging way too
close to water yes what the heck but the
chicken father is Bomb yeah yeah I'll
check it out you like good chicken Pho
I'll give you a whole I have a whole
list of like good fun places okay when I
think of like best and worst things I
it's hard for me to think of like dishes
for some reason maybe I'm just like
thinking about like singular things and
I'm like this is the best of this thing
that I've experienced
um one of the first things comes to mind
is when I was in Barcelona you know like
ebirical ham like hamon uh the [__]
prosciutto ham type stuff these dry aged
cured like [__] legs hanging for like
10 years type [__] wow so I would never
be able to get the expensive ones right
but in Barcelona I was there
um you know there was one of my buddies
he was there for a Tech Convention like
CNET or something like that at the time
and uh they're rich buddies and his
partners and stuff like that would go to
the spot and it's like literally it
sells like those whole [__] dry legs
you can even ship them back home they
sell it out a whole level I set one back
too yeah where and then they have almost
like a cigar room almost like a nice
like Winery or a cigar room there's like
a back room yeah yeah that is like
clothes and [__] has insulation in a
certain way or lightning whatever the
[__] and that's like the really old
stuff right yeah and again I would never
be privy to this if I wasn't with other
[__] rich people and we go there and
the guys that are just like slicing off
samples because if you slice off a
sample and you try it that's how people
know they're willing to spend like 3 500
bucks for a [__] Lego sign yeah
because some of them is like Sashimi
yeah it just melts in your [__] mouth
how long does it last well the thing is
you don't eat like me at like it's so
salty because it's cured so you don't
eat a lot at a time you say how long
does the leg last well the thing is
they're curing it for years or some [__]
yeah it's like it's like wine it's like
whiskey yeah when you open it obviously
you know what I mean yeah just last time
yeah they have peppercorn salami that's
my favorite I have no idea it's like the
most basic one yeah
when I got to try this slice of ibedico
Jamon is that a prosciutto yeah I was
like dude I I don't know if I'll ever
yeah I don't know if I'll ever
experienced it better than this moment
butteriness it was like a [__] little
leg of it but then I forgot what I did
with it God damn dude Chase in your
Vlogs how much did that cost I forgot
over there it's not that expensive
because a case or something because it's
like
it's uh it's kind of like sushi in Japan
it's every day for them
over here it's like marketed it became a
thing where like over and yeah in Japan
you can like 20 bucks will give you some
of the best sushi you've ever ate in
your whole life right over here you have
to spend at least 100 bucks if you want
something that that level yeah you gotta
go SanSai Grill
yeah I was kind of like that dude they
had total for like four bucks in Japan
yeah
yeah and then when I think of the worst
thing I think of an experience I won't
say this is like the worst thing I still
like this on a regular occasion but back
in the day when we were [__] at the
you remember when like the the YouTube
uh space or whatever was like new Playa
Vista yeah and they were bringing people
out to like do content and stuff like
that
I remember a Isa TV was doing like some
sort of game shows yeah I heard of them
yeah well yeah yeah Wong Fu was doing
the same and Phil hit us up me and Mike
I heard I heard A Long food and we went
out there they wanted us to play like
different games and stuff on like
different challenges one of the we
totally won the game uh because we're
awesome but uh we were doing challenges
like giant Chopsticks trying to pick up
stuff or like Post-its all over us and
rolling around and like trying to get as
many off right and in the final game
even though we won this was a punishment
but even though we won in actual scores
they just lied to knew because they
wanted us to they wanted to see us get
punished yeah uh and they rolled out
this car and in one of them was like I
don't remember if it was like guac or
green tea ice cream or something the
other one was wasabi and we didn't know
which one was supposed to be which right
but obviously I think they
and so we we had to take a spoonful
and like Not only was that like and this
is the end of the show so like not only
am I like holding it in you know what I
mean kind of like crying and like not
feeling very comfortable but later on
that day I had such a something I threw
up late like later because I was just
like sitting here you know it was so
gross to like have to adjust something
this is wrong too you know so it's just
discomfort a bowl of Wasabi in it so
[__] [__] up but that is pretty
gross uh who would do that Wong Fu
but you know it was still it was it was
a memorable experience I'll say that so
one of the worst things I ate is either
the Circus Circus buffet
or something my mom made I'm going back
okay something my mom made what would
she cook that was so bad my mom sucked
at cooking oh [__] you should have um
Bart's mom like mukbang so she makes
food and then we all eat it for lunch
and my mom number one she's vegetarian
right so she's already has limited
ingredients number two she's trying to
be on this nutritional tip like she was
[__] like a white hipster before the
white hipsters or even a thing so my mom
used to bake her own bread I shouldn't
even buy bread she bakes her own bread
so we used to have a bread maker when I
was like [__] eight and then she
wants it to be packed with nutrients so
she'll cut up [__] like yams and
dates and [__] she's not even bread
anymore no and then you put them anymore
because she's like she gets the idea of
like raisin bread you know like oh I'll
put other [__] in it she can't wait you
cut you cut the bread down and you hold
the bread up literally looks like a
stained glass window
orange and red whatever she has that
just had no touch that's it yeah then
she goes okay I guess avocados are
healthy so she would chop up uh avocado
and put it in there and she would just
make me the stained glass window avocado
sandwiches with no seasoning though not
even salt on the avocado man it's just
like mush but it wasn't healthy
I don't know but it was like that's like
one of the gnats try not mentally
healthy actually you know what that also
makes you think of in terms of a
different concept of best one time uh
the uh the the some of the leaders of
the Kansas we did a retreat and uh for
this Retreat just to kind of like you
know get into and stuff we want to do a
raw diet right so we didn't eat uh like
processed foods or cooked food this is
all raw so we're just munching and you
know what's weird when you like jump
into a Rada even for just like a three
day experience you actually get like
really tired and stuff like that because
you don't have like the same type of
energy and whatnot you're not consuming
certain types of foods we're just eating
nuts and all this Brands you're gonna
eat cheese right you can't eat none of
that eat ham either but what we were
allowed to eat was an avocado and by the
time like on like the last day yeah the
avocado was like eating a [__] steak
like just getting a little avocado being
able to put [__] salt and pepper in
like lemon juice kind of savory it was
like so delicious because like we hadn't
[__] been able to consume anything
else like oh it was amazing
how long did you guys do it for only for
three days three days it's like the rib
eye of fruits I think yeah but you're
just eating like seeds and nuts and [__]
you know what I mean yeah that's crazy
other fruits and vegetables yeah we're
eating fruits and vegetables but we all
had to be raw yeah all raw but the
avocado was like a [__] stink stage
did you feel good after though after you
did all those three days we felt like
light but it was it's weird because when
you don't eat like the normal Foods you
do like and you're just on Raw stuff
like you actually like it takes um you
just feel like down on energy yeah
you're probably just not so low calorie
dude yeah all the raw like fruits and
vegetables so I remember just like all
of us we thought we had this schedule
and we're like yo we're gonna get to
this [__] thing and then by the time
it's like 10 p.m everybody's like kind
of falling asleep in the middle of like
meetings and stuff because you can't
even have coffee either then no all
wrong
so what did people do back in the day
before bread well I don't think they
have like alarm clocks or like duties
all the time but I could just sleep they
also don't have to do dance shows and
stuff like
they were dancing every night by the
fire dancing more than they're doing
other stuff like lifting weights bro
yeah every jungle people was dancing
when they caught like a [__] gazelle
or something don't count that's
inconsequential they could suck it
doesn't matter
that's true
second best am I right stupid stop doing
that my uh my favorite thing or my best
thing is kind of similar to where um it
was when I was traveling for like shows
with uh six steps this is like 2005 and
I was so freaking broke that you know
when I don't know if any of you have had
the situation where you like don't even
have money to eat with everybody so
you're just like nah I'm good man I'm
good so I just kept saying that yeah and
then we were like on our way to uh San
Francisco and then um finally like some
one of my friends was like hey well I
could just spot you if you want I was
like oh dude you would do that oh thank
God yeah because I didn't really know
them to that level you can spot me at
the grocery store
and then we went to uh Popeyes and I I
hadn't had Popeyes yet until that point
those are first time ever online first
time having Popeyes any and then he goes
I'll just get you like a two-piece or
something I was like all right cool and
I hadn't eaten in like a day and a half
and and that Popeyes was like the best
thing I'd ever eaten did you [__]
jizz yeah I did did you jizz especially
Popeyes is already just worthy and then
if you have never ate it and you haven't
ate in a day starving and I didn't have
any money and I was like from that date
it like triggers it like triggers a
mental thing even now like if I have
Popeyes I'm like oh it's it's good it's
good [__] yeah Popeyes the worst thing I
had was when I tried to eat at Fry's
Electronics yeah the Burbank one had a
cafe oh and it and they designed it to
look like a drive-in so they had like
these 57 Chevys that were cut and they
put seats in them and it looks really
cool but I thought it was like an I was
like hey this would be kind of funny if
like uh we try to eat there because it
you could see that there was like a menu
and like tables so I assumed you could
get food and then so me and smack and we
were like yo like uh can we can we order
something and it was just like this
random kid he was like the only one
working and he was like I think so and
we were like what's uh available we like
we're looking on the menu and all these
different things and he's like I don't
know how to make most of the stuff whoa
I was like what can you make and he was
like I don't know we're like what about
that it was like a grilled cheese
sandwich and he's like no let me ask and
then he goes to the back and then brings
out some other lady and she's like yeah
you just take the bread and put he's
like telling him out loud yeah
no one makes anything there I think this
was the tail end of fries where they
started getting rid of everyone so no
one was left that knew how to do
anything oh she ultimately went bankrupt
because of it like uh incompetent
Staffing yeah so uh incompetent Staffing
is the reason why they went back it's
one of the reasons why people stopped
spending money there wow well because
they they over hired for p and they
didn't train anyone so no one knew how
to answer your question so people just
distrusted fries wow so then ultimately
they you know they they went down for a
lot of other reasons but that's the
consumer I used to love fries yeah so he
made me this [__] yes he took the two
bread and he just put like a slice of
craft singles in it and and like it was
like sort of warm and then we got
grilled cheese we're like What the
[__] we tried to eat it it was like so
old like the bread was like super old
because like nobody had gone there in
ages probably because it wasn't a thing
anymore so they should have just told us
oh we're not doing this anymore but
because this kid wasn't even trained to
tell me no he didn't know what to say
and just gave it to me anyway and it was
the weirdest experience yeah that's
gross
foreign